I wanted to say a little hello to
someone I met yesterday I was in Long
Beach and I went to the the Beach
Festival performed serving no medical
marijuana edible took a Molly threw
water then I went to McDonald's and
McDonald s having the best the guy there
named tyrant a black guy I love black
guys even right right and then I said
yeah he's like oh no I'm sorry man it's
Greg outlet I was like oh [ __ ] you're
really up to date with the jail he asked
for a shout-out here's what I wanted to
mention in my shoutout MacDonald is a
sting recently where you can do 24 hours
you know all day breakfast and I ordered
two hash browns and a lot of catchers
half of the ketchup packets were Mexican
salsa which I never asked for at one
point I put some salsa on my sausage
McMuffin and it was a really spicy
sausage McMuffin it made me very
uncomfortable I didn't enjoy the
sandwich then you know what I thought
would really make this better
I'll just eat my next hash brown which
wasn't in the bag but on the receipt Wow
they stole a hash brown from you so you
say you're a fan Tyron oh I feel like
you have to take me down no wait here's
our review for ghostbusters
today they against bus those fines mall
name's Greg and my name is John I'm
little sunburned today I was at the
beach all day yesterday anyway we're
gonna talk about Ghostbusters 2016 know
as critics i gotto establish up front
that at first when i saw the trailers
for this i thought it was gonna be a
piece of [ __ ] dude you poop what i am
here today to tell you right now up
front i was pleasantly surprised by this
film i had a great time watching and i
thought it was a really really fun time
the cast I thought was great if we're
gonna talk about you know like the
biggest worry the most hammered talking
point yeah I think it's really cool that
we got a female Ghostbusters yeah as I
first thought like well this would have
been better if they did it as a sequel
so there's just can the whole thing
however after watching this film I'm
like okay these guys are this is not
female Bill Murray female dan Aykroyd
it's like yeah okay yeah they're the
representation of that archetype in a
way but they're still very different
those personalities a kooky bunch of
colorful characters and there's a
balance of some of them are more broad
and some of them are more straight and
and yeah they're a believable team it's
it's for comedians that we like come
together just like the first you know
what I like about what the cast it too
is like everyone keeps saying that Kate
McKinnon and Leslie Jones steal the show
well I do think they are more
highlighted in terms of the comedy I
like that Kristen Wiig and Melissa
McCarthy didn't try to you like outshine
them cuz you still feel like they are
the leads of the film well you got these
other characters who are like there for
the comedic purposes primarily you know
well yeah it like it gives them the
chance to shine as the comedy of the
move in and I appreciated that Cocina
we've seen Kristen Wiig and Melissa
McCarthy both play big broad characters
and I've seen them work together before
- yeah yes I thought this was cool to
see them play you know still kooky but
more straight more subtle characters
having to be really immersed in their
science
- what boomed Kristen Wiig a Melissa
McCarthy was bridesmaids and they're
very different characters and
bridesmaids yeah I feel like people
forget that because when you watch this
I'm like hey
I really believe this new dynamic
there's new relationship there like with
these characters I'm not like thinking
this is different than what I lost often
these guys too yeah yeah what I got
Stacy was like I love what they did with
Leslie Jones because I know the
backstory when it came with like in the
original Ghostbusters they wanted to
cast Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy couldn't
do it so then they cut out the character
a lot the black character and then they
put in Ernie Hudson like barely in the
fiddle and they kind of put him in the
background I like that one this time
they're like okay well let's all female
cast we'll get a black character and I
like how they do like most people are
walking out saying like she really did
shine in this film yet and kudos to the
blacks right kudos to the blacks the
blacks
Kate McKinnon I could see people having
issues with if you're kind of like on
the fence about her because she is like
kind of doing her own thing every scene
character but but I heard there's
something so kind of assured about the
way she played it that yeah especially
when the movie starts to hook cuz it
took me maybe you know 20 minutes 25
minutes to like really just lose myself
in the groove of the movie cuz I thought
the opening was really strong and then
when they start to introduce this story
it's just a little kind of bumpy at
first and then once the movie hits the
groove like that's what everybody
started to yeah I felt like once like
okay we see the gun the first ghost now
yeah and then that all started happening
I feel like the film had a great flow
throughout I prefer the first half over
the last half i like the journey of them
you know coming together and figuring
this all out and you know I like to get
this out of the way yeah okay the
structure especially the first stop is
very similar to the structure of the
original Ghostbusters filters you know
just a wigs character she's a scientist
who has like a interesting ghost but
doesn't but kind of just doesn't really
go after it and those kind of worry
whatever Kristen Wiig like like she
clearly had some interest in this and
she's trying to bury it so that she can
have a legitimate career yeah and
Melissa McCarthy's like the dad a core
character and that sense of she's like
the super scientist like super sassy
ghosts so yeah but then you got then I
like how Kate McKinnon was like
the representation of the Harold Ramis
character but it's so different cuz he
they could have easily made her like I'm
really straightforward I'm really like
just yeah done what hell Grammys did but
she's just so wacky
she's totally wacky and she's also like
the tech head who yeah like she'll say
something kooky and be funny but then
the next scene she'll be like I built
this crazy [ __ ] even she in being that
wacky character is still like a really
cool character cuz she's you know a tech
wizard the structure of it was similar
in the sense that like they don't really
believe they believe they see a ghost
now Kristen Wiig is like oh this is real
yeah like they take time to basically
convey the characters to go on this
journey yeah and then similar stuff
starts to happen but it's not so obvious
and so in my face where I'm like this is
this is a new hope I'm kind of okay with
that concept it's like yeah you're
you're not fully doing a remake but you
are borrowing some structural things to
get this going you're borrowing you know
the steps that works but they also put a
lot of their own flavor and a lot of
their own character on it but I was glad
that if they're gonna do this that they
did make it a different film and not a
sequel because at first I was like I
thought this should have been a sequel
and then after watching it and then you
know like yeah you get the cameos from
Bill Murray Aykroyd Hudson and uh of
course I remember name Weaver name's
Barney we were yeah that's right like
that so you do get your cameos and all
of the cameras I didn't really think of
that funny it was still cool to
establish that this is a separate movie
a separate universe yeah yeah because it
still felt like most of the original
cast is still around know if they wanted
to they could still do it Ghostbusters
Part 3 would the original cast if they
wanted to also it's cool to have this
other world of the final Ghostbusters
cuz I just got to keep saying I love how
these female Ghostbusters are not female
mimics of the original cast there's
super different people which makes it a
comedy worth being on board for for as
much arguing and discussion as there's
been about Lady Ghostbusters the movie
itself doesn't call a lot of attention
to it doesn't happen time going if
they're women and Leia I love that house
for women who happen to
the people getting together to do this
they happen to be those people and
that's a really nice thing about the
movie because that does allow you just
to kind of get to know these new
characters yeah
the structure is familiar but the
characters do feel new I've heard a lot
of people say that the movie kind of
borrowed is totally from the Real
Ghostbusters cartoon - I like that they
also brought that in because it seems
like this Ghostbusters loves
Ghostbusters just as much as everybody
else does
yeah exactly but I watched I was like
they clearly cared about this and even
in the designs like I thought the the
world they drew was cool and it doesn't
look like everything else right now as I
was saying earlier the second half of
the film though what I recall from
feeling it was I did feel that the fun
started to kind of wither away a little
bit I felt they got a little too caught
up and plot because I felt like the
first half was very much like the
interactions and a lot of the fun with
the characters and the discoveries and
the last half got more focused on its
villain knew who was okay not he's not
like good memories yeah but I think it's
an appropriate because it's appropriate
because you don't want the villain of
steal the show and without giving away
too much the way they use the villain
allows for other things in the movie to
to kind of get even better yes I'll say
that I say that too and Chris Hemsworth
Rock Chris Hemsworth I thought was
really [ __ ] funny I thought is
hilarious at first I was like okay
within like two seconds later cracky was
doing like he's so funny this and I was
actually really I was really happy about
his performance in this we've seen the
Thor movies and stuff like that he's
been doing these either action or heavy
dramas and I'm like I'm happy he mixed
it up and it seems like he had the most
fun of the world playing the dumbest
most self-assured he nailed it my
favorite lines are probably from him oh
yeah and I think my favorite lines are
broken and again that's a character that
they use really wisely because you know
with these kinds of comedies especially
these banter based you things kind of
broad comedies and especially you know
in some Paul figs in the movies it's
easy to get lost in like crazy banter
and outlandish jokes they use Chris
Hemsworth for the most wacky stuff and
just the right amount when it comes to
like stupidity and wackiness yeah he's
been
ridiculous for sure but that's the thing
I like too and that but it adds like it
seemed like he had a great time doing
this and it's always nice to watch an
actor have a really good time of the
world getting a phone call oh my god
hello oh you're here oh wow yeah okay um
just wait out front I'll grab you in a
minute and going back to Kate McKinnon
is like Hema Kate McKinnon is also like
heightened and wacky but she doesn't
play it like a character who says wacky
things it's just it's what that
character would say after a while yes
like she plays that like a fully
realized character and she's she's
terrific defense I thought the action
sequences in the finale yeah like I at
first when I saw the trailers a little
worried about that that was gonna go
like so Hollywood on it I honestly like
the finale I thought I didn't say yeah
it was a cool like going through your
kind of adventure and I thought some of
the action scenes were really [ __ ]
cool like they looked really cool
because in the first Ghostbusters that's
something I actually never thought about
were the action sequences I never viewed
it as having action yeah yeah I'm like
doing some type of like fire hose thing
with the what's it called the proton
yeah the proton pack and this one Kate
McKinnon is able to design several kinds
of gadgets so we get to see the
different characters use several
different kinds of gadgets and it makes
for much cooler action the influences I
like oh yeah my fan did it yeah I never
thought that Ghostbusters could have
really cool action sympathetic when the
action goes down like it is they don't
skip it's not like a horror movie but
they do they do not skimp on the
creepiness and and the Menace of the
ghosts it's like it's still fun and
funny but when they got a fight like you
do get a sense for the peril yeah and
it's not too big and they do take a lot
of time to show the city and what's
going on it's not like a lot of the
other blockbusters where they just
decimate all of New York and you know
it's yeah lots of alien monsters it's
like they centralize everything because
that's shot in the trailer with the big
vortex kind of worried me but when it
came up in the movie on
yeah I thought the boy was well
structured I mean I'm the second half it
felt kind of slowed down a little bit in
terms of a disappointment I would say
the Cameo is specifically Bill Murray's
cameo what like was they like try making
a more of a character think cameo I
still didn't like I was like I was a lot
of jokes like especially Bill Murray's
character was making Rob like I know no
one's laughing and I'm not either I feel
like he was trying on looks like it that
was a character I didn't feel like was
trying to be funny
maybe yeah I mean the cameos aren't like
like they just show up yeah Korea is
pretty big and his eye I did like sort
of woof at but I really yeah I think
they slipped them in nicely like nice to
have to be like ah yeah but also like
hey and we're doing something kind of
cool it was more than them just saying
hi yeah exactly or popping in for like a
very blatant huh yeah it wasn't like
Stanley I actually thought the second
half picked up momentum for me because
like I like little first half took time
to introduce everybody natural weird
it's the first half of the second half
that ball that kind of slowed down for
me okay that's a lot of the commies
started withering away and that's the
situation gets worse and it's started
yet yeah it gets more serious but then
and then it starts picking up the fun a
lot more yeah and you know yeah it's
probably was a small portion now can sum
it up in terms of in comparison to the
original do I like you more than
original I I don't does that bad no cuz
I still think it's a wonderful addition
I reckon he goes better than
Ghostbusters - yeah yeah I think this
was a really fun film and I think over
time it'll be even more appreciate when
I feel like this smart thing about the
way they approach this is I don't feel
like you have to if they straight-up
remade Ghostbusters like no for know I
think you would have to kind of have
that argument and this is like it's kind
of in its own universe and you know it's
it's the perfect 2016 goes Astor's it's
26 - 2016 Ghostbusters yeah I say I
afraid note Ghostbusters - yes my
consent
I would love a Ghostbusters - I ain't
afraid of no I don't land backlash
so do you hate us like the movie thank
you hey thanks sorry for paying us
$5,000 to recommend the Ghostbusters for
female movies right we actually haven't
even seen it we haven't seen it we're
just saying what everyone else is said
on Rotten Tomatoes if I named the
channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject maybe if you want to who
knows I don't care yes I do I like the
number Sean
Jerry blue Mouse